now thank you for joining us here at
noon i'm hector mejia we start with an
update on that major freeway closure of
the 95 a crash between a fuel tank and a
car kept both directions of u.s 95
closed between jones and rancho during
the morning rush hour still closed right
now this is a live look at the scene
from one of our traffic cameras fire
trucks still cleaning up fuel that
spilled on highway lanes bianca holman
joins us live with the latest on this
situation bianca
good afternoon hector so the fuel in the
first tank was pumped out into a second
take they had to do that first before
they actually could turn the tank that
was turned on its side right side up so
let me show you what's happening now now
that that fuel is out of the first tank
the tow trucks you can see them there
they can now lift that tank up and get
it out of the way and clear it from this
area on the u.s 95. this all stems from
a crash that happened at 4 30 this
morning a bmw and truck carrying
thousands of gallons of fuel crashed on
the northbound side of u.s 95
right past valley view no one was
hospitalized or suffered major injuries
fire officials tell us there was a small
leak the it spilled about less than 100
gallons of fuel onto the road
since there is about 8 500 gallons in
the tank which equals 80 thousand pounds
the liquid must be removed first then
the tank can be turned right side up by
a large tow truck which is on scene now
and this is a situation that takes
multiple crews to handle
when we got there everybody got together
talked about what they were going to do
and everything was taken care of nhp got
that traffic out of there along with
metro our team surrounded it made sure
nobody was hurt d.o.t arrived to put up
cones they brought us extra materials
for absorbent everything came together
real well
exactly lots of moving pieces to this
the fire hazardous team using little
dams and they use sand to absorb the
fuel so that it didn't flow down the
road or impact the environment or even
cause an explosion that was a major
factor matter of fact we had to move
several different times away from the
scene while they cleaned that up because
there was a danger of explosion so still
on scene right now you can see the tow
trucks about to turn that fuel tank on
its
right side up so that it can be moved
out of the way and we're told the fuel
is salvageable there was no containment
to the fuel and also we're told that a
u.s 95 southbound should be open within
the next 30 minutes to an hour and then
northbound of course following that once
they clear this tanker out of the way
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now